[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous trouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois un yvelinois il
s'appelle jean garrigues il est
historien universitaire et auteur il
sort un nouveau livre qui s'appelle une
histoire érotique de l'elysée jean
garrigues bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et vous êtes
donc ce que j'ai dit oh rien university
auteur bien sûr et aussi président du
comité d'histoire parlementaire et
politique
qu'est ce que c'est que cette fonction
d'abord j'ai même enseigne et tout près
ici à l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines ce sujet il dira après faut
quand même swing j'allais dire après le
président de président du comité
histoire c'était un comité que j'avais
créée il ya vingt ans maintenant ouais
au moment d'ailleurs les élections de
2002 pour essayer de rappeler un petit
peu aux universitaires et au grand
public ce que la richesse de ce qu'a été
notre vie parlementaire qui a tendance
vème république un peu à situer et donc
à travers des soutenances de thèse un
séminaire que nous tenons à sciences po
des colloques des conférences
des publications aussi doublage une
revue qui s'appelle parlement on essaie
de rappeler à quel point c'est important
d'avoir une vie parlementaire active est
dérisoire riche et vivante alors que la
cinquième république a eu un peu
tendance à la halle à négliger je
comprends très bien donc vous présidez
cette association oui c'est une
association loi 1901 non lucrative très
bien alors aujourd'hui on est là pour ce
livre une histoire érotique de l'elysée
voilà vous avez alors sous titré de la
pompadour au paparazzi alors la
pompadour ça fait tilt en tant que
yvelinois la faune pas donc forcément
c'est versailles l'elysée n'est pas à
versailles que je sache mais
racontez-nous quand même un peu cette
histoire
de l'elysée du départ en fait on va voir
après des des visuels sur l'hôtel
d'evreux qu'il était auparavant c'est
une histoire qui est érotique et
sulfureuse dès le début en réalité parce
que l'homme qui a fait construire ce
palais cet hôtel particulier on va des
champs elysées au départ c'était un des
grands du royaume on est au xviiie
siècle et il a ne fait construire pour
pour simplifier fait construire ce ce
château avec cet hôtel particulier
pardon avec l'argent de sa femme qui
était une roturière une bourgeoise et ce
conte d'evreux donc dès qu il s est
installé dans le palais de l'élysée a
dit à sa femme écoute j'ai plus besoin
de toi tu retournes dans ta dans sa
province et moi je m'installe avec ma
maîtresse l'acompte est
d'une très grande élégance cette femme
elle était très jeune femme
voilà elle était en plus il ya du tour
prendre c'était une enfant oui alors en
ce moment là elle était déjà le thé déjà
les prestations à ce que presque muette
raffiné mais elle a été quand même assez
des suppressions
de son volage épouse yaël pour pas dire
valeur troupes a dit aux joueurs on est
d'accord alors après qu'est ce qui s'est
passé donc notre rapport à versailles il
arrive là je crois après il ya eu
notamment la marquise de pompadour qui
met en fait on est plutôt sur la fin de
jaillir du règne au cadeau de son
rayonnement les sélections et de
séduction exactement elle est devenue
plutôt une conseillère une annie du roi
2015 et et on disait notamment qu'elle
était
lorientais beaucoup dans le choix de ses
de ces jeunes maîtresses mais elle s'est
installée là elle a vécu assez
malheureuse finalement parce que parce
que sa fille est morte oui qu'elle
aimait vous l'expliquer qui était tout
jeune et bon c'est plutôt un moment
assez sombre de la vie de la marquise de
pompadour d'autant plus qu'elle était
détesté par là par les parisiens parce
qu'elle avait fait faire des
aménagements autour du palais de
l'elysée qui sont pas l'origine du parc
qui autour d'aujourd'hui et
d'aujourd'hui que ça avait lésé beaucoup
de cultivateurs parce que c'était ok il
y avait des champs dégagé qui se connaît
c'était très agricole et donc ça n'a pas
été vraiment un très beau moment pour
elle mais néanmoins elle continuait à
faire son marché pour lou 15 donc à lui
chercher d'après ce qu'on m'a dit mais
ce petit jeune fille oui au plaisir pur
surtout pas qu'ils attrapent de maladies
exactement voilà elle et lui ramenait
parc aux cerfs à versailles dans une
petite maison du café salle où
exactement voilà c'était son travail
dans les yvelines on est toujours
voilà alors après cela et bien ils sont
dépassés d'autres où vous croyez vous en
la mémoire des murs des des lieux que
c'est ce que c'est c'est drôle parce que
c'est un peu ce qui rebute el général de
gaulle lorsqu'il s'est installé à
l'elysée elysée c c'est un palais pour
le plaisir palais daming gauche lui leur
ai souhaité s'installer dans des lieux
plus austère plus sont imprégnés de
luxure exactement il pensait à aux
invalides y penser au château de
vincennes beaucoup plus voilà masini
fait et austère et donc c'est parce
qu'il ya eu toute une histoire dense est
dans ce palais de l'elysée mais qui est
lié en réalité d'abord sous l'ancien
régime à ce goût de la côte
courtisanerie de la séduction du luxe
etc et puis qui ensuite est liée à ce
set comment dire ça ce parallélisme
entre le goût du pouvoir et le goût de
la séduction c'est à dire que ceux qui
sont au pouvoir ont quand même très
souvent une sorte de lien particulier
avec les hantises la sexualité et ce
besoin de conquérir les uns qui leur est
donné presque naturellement par le fait
qu'ils détiennent ce pouvoir politique
mais alors qui de la poule et de l'oeuf
c'est qu'ils l'ont avant avant cette
volonté de séduire un barreau de chaise
et du coup ccc dans leur adn c'est de
leur caractère sorte de cercle vicieux
oui et non oui kissinger qui était le
secrétaire d'état de richard nixon
disait que le pouvoir le plus puissant
des aphrodisiaques donc ça c'est une
certitude la détention du pouvoir
attirer un certain nombre de femmes
alors si ray c'est peut-être aujourd'hui
moi mon le cas et en même temps le fait
d'être arrivé là à ce degré du pouvoir
montre une une capacité non seulement à
conquérir mais à séduire aussi qui fait
que éventuellement vous pouvez avoir des
prédispositions à
à séduire les femmes d'accord et puis à
voir est ce que c est ce qu on peut
comparer parce qu'avant de gaulle donc
il y a eu énormément de chefs d'état qui
ont eu énormément de mai de liaison de
maîtresses caché moins cachées etc c'est
un peu la valse permanente mais voilà
est-ce qu'on peut comparer ses hommes à
un petit un petit enfant dans une
pâtisserie on le dit vas-y tout tout est
à toi mon ce que tu veux ou alors c'est
plus quelqu'un qui se rate sur rai aux
dix ans bah tiens j'ai eu tant est
tellement de conquête c'est que je suis
comme quelqu'un de très très très
important il ya un peu il ya un peu des
deux selon les périodes prenons
l'exemple
de napoléon iii napoléon iii qui a vécu
finalement assez peu de temps à l'elysée
il n'y a vécu pas en tant qu'empereur
met d'abord en tant que président de la
république car avant son coup d'état du
2 décembre 1851 il l'était qu'ils
n'étaient que président de la république
c'est à dire le premier président de la
république
louis napoléon bonaparte donc devenu
napoléon iii était un véritable
érotomane dire qu'il avait un appétit de
séduction et de sexualité qui était
quelque chose de faramineux d'autres les
hommes de là de la troisième république
par exemple qui sont venus donc après on
est à la fin du 19ème début du 20e
siècle mais plutôt des des hommes qui
ont une double vie en réalité qui ont
besoin à côté de leur vie publique
officielle leurs épouses et c'est
d'avoir deux maîtresses on est dans les
années 1870 1914 on est bons l'exemple
typique ce serait ce fameux président de
la république félix faure qui est mort
comme on sait en 1899 dans les bras de
sa maîtresse naissance voilà il a perdu
sa connaissance
et est très méchamment clémenceau disait
il se voulait césar il est mort pompéi
est ce que sa maîtresse mme externe elle
était dans une situation particulière
avec lumix dans ce salon d'argent de
l'elysée où on reste intacte d'ailleurs
le le canapé où se seraient produits
c'est le drame ce drame ce drame en fait
il est mort un peu de top plutôt de
l'elysée quand je suis mais c'est là que
ça s'est passé bon en attendant
comment dire donc jusqu'à jusqu'à de
gaulle ça a été un peu comme ça après de
gaulle bon beaucoup plus sage on s'est
calmé pompidou même combat on s'est
calmé et après ça a repris mais oui
c'est ça qui est très intéressant c'est
que les présidents de la vème république
sont des monarques républicains ils ont
des pouvoirs exorbitants qui sont sans
doute les pouvoirs les objectivement les
pouvoirs politiques les plus importantes
de toute la sphère mondiale je mets de
côté les dictatures donc dans les
démocraties il n'y a pas plus de pouvoir
aucun président de la république
française sous la vème république et
donc de manière presque assez naturel
ces hommes là se sont comportés comme se
comportaient les monarques ou les grands
du royaume dans l'ancien régime c'est à
dire avec une frénésie de de conquête
totalement décomplexé une vision de la
femme quand même plutôt la femme trophée
la femme la femme objet un besoin de
séduire aussi très fort que ce soit un
valéry giscard d'estaing françois
mitterrand ce sont d'abord des
séducteurs étaient protégés parce que
tout était cachée et voilà et il
bénéficie
voilà quelques complices d'une seconde
savais pas ça ne disait exactement il
bénéficie d'une forme d'omerta qui a
permis par exemple à jacques chirac
quand il était premier ministre d'être
fou amoureux d'une journaliste à qui il
a même failli éventuellement se s'enfuir
et quitter meubles la vie politique
françois mitterrand qui a mené une
double vie mais c'était en fait une
triple quadruples quintuple vie
puisqu'il a eu beaucoup de deux
maîtresses d'aventuré et voilà oui alors
leur femme légitime dans tout ça elles
ont quand même accepter un sacré deal
parce que l avais sale boulot entre
guillemets dans la décoration mais pas
que parce que j'imagine que que se taper
les commémorations les voyages
d'affaires les enfants repas d'affaires
mais les voyages sont pas forcément
peut-être très rigolo sachant que peu
après il y avait des géoliers jeune
fille qui attendait leur époux
voilà raison d'accepter ben oui que ce
soit anne-aymone giscard d'estaing
danielle mitterrand le madame chirac
mais rennes
l1 ont beaucoup souffert mais ont
accepté au nom de d'abord d'un comment
dirais-je d'une sorte de
besoin de justement ou de 2,2 de devoir
vis-à-vis de leurs époux au
bout il y avait le pouvoir suprême une
sorte de deal de contraindre ceux de
contrat de marie tu aller jusqu'au
sommet et puis aussi parce que des
convives est quand même encore sur des
principes très très archaïque wi fi sont
soumises voilà tout ça près j'accélère
un tout petit peu parce que malheur
c'est bientôt l'heure
après l'eau les autres femmes on parle
de 2 2
cécilia et carla puis valérie
trierweiler eh ben elle elles n'ont pas
accepter ça non mais n'aurait jamais
accepté n'ont pas trait à valeur valérie
pas non elle a bien mis les pieds dans
le plat est exactement essais face à lui
a coûté cher enfin la halle a failli
perdre la vie mais mais c'est vraiment
une rebelle et nouvelle c'est une
nouvelle une nouvelle génération à la
rébellion
on voit bien que c'est sarkozy n'a pas
accepté les codes de cette
gouvernance pareil pour valérie
trierweiler et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui visite macro
n'accepterait pas à ce type de
traitement est fortement et stress et
nous non plus l'opinion critique non
plus et c'est fondamental
ces limites ringard ci se termine oui
c'est totalement ringard c'est ça ça
ressemble je le répète c'est la
reproduction et c'est ça au fond de moi
qui m'a fasciné dans le fait de raconter
cette histoire sur le temps long c'est
que on a reproduit il ya 20 30 ans des
comportements qui étaient ceux des je le
répète des aristocrates du xviie ou
xviiie siècle ça c'est quand même très
très très troublant mais aujourd'hui
cédant à l'époque de mitu à l'époque
delà de l'information je dirais en temps
réel ça n'est plus possible il n'est
plus possible de restaurer plus les
femmes les femmes n'acceptent
voilà une bonne nouvelle
j'espère que après j'avais une chance
ben oui y'a pas de raison j'avais une
autre petite question je me demandais
mais comment il arrivait à gouverner
alors je vous demanderai de répondre
assez vite je crois je déborde comment
arrivent et il a gouverné en ayant en
tête
la jeune femme du début de l'après midi
celle du milieu celle du soir celle du
lendemain en fin c'était tellement
naturel pour eux c'est d'abord ce sont
des gens qui ont des grandes capacités
intellectuelles mais je pense c'était
tellement naturel pour us intégrer
naturellement tourné vers facile de
travail
c'était naturel alors aux garrigues un
grand merci c'est pas ce numéro
j'encourage tout le monde à à lire ça
parce qu'on veut en même temps
l'évolution de la société exacte ainsi
que des comportements qui correspondent
évidemment au comportement des
gouvernants actuels voilà vous avez un
nouveau livre parce que vous écrivez
beaucoup apparemment qui s'appelle ça
s'appelle la tentation du sauveur
l'histoire d'une passion française alors
peut-être qu'un jour on en reparlera
avec grand plaisir bon en tout cas déjà
merci beaucoup pour cette histoire
érotique de l'isi et passionnante mais
est très vite très vite merci merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi et à très
bientôt pour un nouveau vip
[Musique]